want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how you can manifest abundance
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one visualize the bridge with mel
robbins here's what everybody gets wrong
about manifesting
everybody at least kind of in the mass
market
what you're trained to think about when
you think about manifesting is vision
boards and when you hear the word vision
boards you think about the big stuff
should you have big dreams of course you
should should you dream of building a
mansion on the ocean if that's your
thing yes should you dream of the log
cabin yes if you want a lamborghini or
the new ford bronco should you put yeah
yes yes yes if you want the family if
you want the body should you think about
yeah absolutely here's where everybody
goes wrong
you
dream about the end you make this
gorgeous collage of all this stuff
that has nothing to do with your current
life
that literally as you're sitting in your
studio apartment with the cat box that
hasn't been changed in two weeks no food
in the fridge no fruit in the fridge and
you're looking for a job and you're
staring at a mansion going someday
it's going to make you feel like a loser
because the gap between where you are
and where you want to go
it seems insurmountable
and so what happens based on the
research is when you only visualize the
endgame lewis it's demotivating at first
it's really fun to like have a bottle of
wine and make your like collage i'm
gonna visualize i'm gonna slap this up
there's my vision for this fabulous law
of attraction baby come on i'm gonna
think about it it's gonna come to me
okay i've been doing this for two days
i'm not i'm still in this apartment with
the cat box that needs to be changed
the way
to visualize properly is to visualize
the bridge
between where you are
and where you need to go the bridge yes
and particularly
the horrible stuff
so let's use your example of the
marathon
the vision board would be lewis crossing
the arms up at the back
yes i did it exactly
that will not help you because when you
hit mile 13 on the actual race and it is
sleeting range you say why am i doing
this yes and it feels nothing like that
thing on your vision board you're going
to start a negative dialogue i can't do
this my knees hurt this is not what i
thought it was going to be i'm not ready
for this i didn't train for this i'm
running new york i trained in la are you
running in here l.a okay good well then
at least you're trained in the right
weather so on and on and on and you are
going to tank yourself
what you do by visualizing the bridge is
you train your nervous system
and your mind
to do the hard work
so you should visualize
not crossing the finish line but what is
it like to be at mile 12 when your
batteries run out on your earbuds yeah
i'm serious and you keep going
what's it like when your shoelace breaks
and now your heel is lifting and you're
starting to get a blood blister at mile
17. what's it feel like when you wake up
and it is pouring rain
and you visualize yourself
running anyway
that way when you visualize the work
you are preparing your body for it so
you're not resistant to it when it comes
rule number two think greater than your
environment with dr joe dispenza every
time you have a thought you make a
chemical
and if you have a great thought or an
unlimited thought or a joyful thought
you turn on a set of circuits in your
brain that fires in a very specific
sequence pattern and combination that
produces a level of mind
that turns on another part of the brain
that makes a chemical for you to begin
to feel exactly the way you were just
thinking great or unlimited or joyful
now if you have a negative thought or an
unhappy thought or a self-depreciating
thought
you turn on a different set of circuits
in a different combination a different
sequence and a different pattern that
produces a different level of mind and
the brain then begins to make a
different batch of chemicals that
signals the body for you to begin to
feel exactly the way you were just
thinking negative or unhappy or unworthy
so the moment you begin to feel the way
you think because the brain is in
constant communication with your body
you begin to think the way you feel
which makes more chemicals for you to
feel the way you think
and then you think the way you feel and
then you feel the way you think and then
you think the way you feel and some
people do this for 20 or 30 or 40 years
now the redundancy of that cycle over
time creates what i call a state of
being
in a state of being is when your mind
and body are working together or your
thoughts or and feelings are aligned to
a concept
so thoughts are the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body
and as people get caught in this cycle
of thinking and feeling and feeling and
thinking over time they condition their
body to memorize that emotion as well as
the conscious mind and whenever the body
knows as well as the mind that's called
a habit a habit is when your body is the
mind now 95 percent of who you are
by the time you're 35 years old
is a set of memorized behaviors
set of emotional reactions beliefs
perceptions attitudes that run just like
a computer program
so five percent of your conscious mind
begins to work against 95 percent of
what you've memorized
so the person wants to think positively
but they're feeling negatively
they want to create their dream board
you know and put up their future life
but they feel unworthy
that's mind and body and opposition we
have to recondition the body to a new
mind
so how many people here know someone
who's memorized suffering
doesn't have to be you it could be
anybody
and you say to that person hey did you
read the book i gave you what do they
say
no
did you see the dvd i gave you oh no
hey listen we're gonna go out to dinner
we're gonna go see some stand-up comedy
and go for a walk along the water you
want to come
no
what are they saying i'm insisting on
this neurochemical order that no person
no thing no experience can move us from
it and we have these three brains to
allow us to move into a new state of
being and the quantum field
universal mind whatever you want to call
it responds to who you're being
not what you're thinking not what you're
feeling but the combination of how
you're thinking and how you're feeling
called a state of being now most people
wait for what crisis or trauma or
disease or loss or
diagnosis to really want to change they
wait to the point where the ego's
brought to such a low level that they
cannot go on business as usual any
longer that's when we begin to look at
how we're thinking or what we believe or
how we act our attitude
or what emotions we're living by
and my message is why wait
we can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering which tends to be the
human model
or we can learn and change in a state of
joy and inspiration
now you want to learn the hardest part
about all of this
you ready
the hardest part of all of this
the hardest part of all of this
is making the time to do it that's it
rule number three entertain the idea
with bob proctor i think james allen put
it very well in his little book as a man
thinketh he said you don't attract what
you want you attract what you are
now think about that
if you want to attract what you want
you've got to see yourself already with
it you've got to understand that you've
already got it
first of all clearly understand this
nothing is created or destroyed that
means everything's already here if not
in one state certainly in another
where did the iphone come from the
iphone came from a series of ideas that
individuals entertained in their mind
and they kept holding the idea until the
stuff came to them that enabled them to
build the phone the stuff had already
been here
nothing is created or destroyed all
science all theology teach that if
nothing's created or destroyed
everything that is already here
our problem is we've got to wait until
we see it outside before we believe
we've got it start dealing with the
non-physical world with the invisible
world with the world that you can't see
through these little peepers that you've
got here we call eyes
start to see yourself mentally you've
been given the faculties to do that use
your imagination see yourself already in
possession of the good you desire
that will flip your mind onto a specific
frequency and you do think on
frequencies it's on that frequency that
good you desire is going to start coming
towards you and you will start moving
toward it
if you want to attract what you actually
want you've got to see yourself now
already with it and no it's only a
period of time until you moving toward
it and it moving toward you and you
become one with it
that is how it's done
james allen was right
you don't get what you want you get what
you are
you've got to become what you want
you've got to realize that the minute
you hold your mind in harmony with the
good you want
then you've already got it it's only a
period of time until it manifests in
physical form you've got it
intellectually and you can talk to
somebody about it you've got it
emotional you can share your feelings
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form that's called the perpetual
transmutation of energy
that is a law the first law of the
universe
do it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four have spontaneous
creativity with deepak chopra wealth is
a state of consciousness
it's not the amount of money it's the
state of consciousness that you can
generate
wealth and abundance
and so what is that state of
consciousness
it's actually a state of consciousness
that i call spontaneous
creativity
spontaneous creativity
and comes when
there is
a pause between
what we call
experience the gap between thoughts the
gap between
intention the gap between perception
the gap between breath
the space between
choices
same place which i mentioned in the
first
principle
the infinite
self
where there is spontaneous creativity
you know when there is spontaneous
creativity
when
there is no resistance
when there is no anticipation
when there is no
regret
when you're totally present
and you're experiencing what is called
flow
because you know
deep inside you
that you're only intention
ultimately
is the progressive expansion of
happiness for yourself
and for everyone else
and as you do that
then that spontaneous creativity
will activate
intention
which
will find
the creative
source
for fulfilling that intention as i've
said so many times before
intention has
organizing power
and intention
organizes its own fulfillment rule
number five release the negative pattern
with louise hay the more self-hatred and
guilt we have the less our life works
we find we have an inability to speak up
for ourselves
and we're always trying to please others
or
we may be angry and explosive all the
time
the less self-hatred and guilt we have
the better our lives work
on all levels this includes the health
of the body too
it has been my experience that the very
bottom line for everyone i have worked
with is always i'm not good enough
and we often add to this i don't do
enough or
i don't deserve
does this sound like you
always saying or implying or feeling
that you are not good enough
but for whom
and according to whose standards
now if these negative beliefs are very
strong in you
then how can you possibly create a
loving joyous prosperous healthy life
somehow your subconscious beliefs would
always be contradicting you and making
sure you do not obtain your goals
i find that resentment criticism guilt
and fear
cause more problems in our bodies and in
our experiences than anything else
these feelings come from blaming others
and not taking responsibility
for our own lives
you see if we are all responsible for
everything that happens in our lives
then there is really no one to blame
whatever is happening out there is only
a mirror of our own inner thinking
i am not condoning other people's poor
behavior
but we must realize it is our beliefs
that attract to us people that will
treat us in that way
if you find yourself saying everyone
always does such and such to me
criticizes me ignores me takes advantage
of me or abuses me then this is your
pattern
there is some thought in you
that attracts this behavior
on some internal level you believe you
deserve to be treated this way or
you treat other people this way
and it is just coming back to you
whatever we give out
mental physical or verbal
will always come back to us
when we no longer think or behave in
this way
the other people will change their
behavior
or they will go and do that to someone
else who believes they deserve it
you will no longer be attracting the
experiences you say you do not want
whether we want to change a life
experience or a physical problem the
place to begin is to say so
literally say
i am willing to release the pattern
within me
that is creating this experience or this
condition
you can say this to yourself over and
over every time you think of your
illness
say this with me now
i am willing to release the pattern in
me
that has created this condition
the minute you say this affirmation you
are stepping out of the victim role you
are no longer helpless
you are acknowledging your own power
you are saying i may not quite
understand it but somehow i'm beginning
to understand that i contributed to
creating this problem and now i take my
own power back
and i am releasing it and letting it go
what a powerful statement to have your
subconscious mind supporting rule number
six
surrender with gabby bernstein every
single one of us in this room today is
trying to control something you know
what i'm talking about
you all know what it is
maybe you're trying to control that ring
that you're trying to get on your finger
or maybe you're trying to control when
you're going to get that cash in the
bank or maybe you're trying to control
the outcome of a physical diagnosis but
all that control and all that
manipulation all that trying to make
something happen
is creating resistance
resistance from the alignment resistance
from that intuitive voice that is
beckoning you all the time resistance
from your connection to a power far
greater than yourself a magnitude that
is within you that you have forgot to
listen to because you've been too busy
focused on what you need to get
but it's in the absence of that
resistance that we re-align
it's in the absence of that resistance
that we remember the truth of who we are
it's in the absence of that resistance
that we get connected to the universe
and the universe is an ever-present
energy of love that is within us and
around us and always guiding us and
these are the steps to spiritual
surrender so that you can know that the
universe has your back even when things
are not working out the way that you
expected
you ready
step one step one
take your hands off the wheel through
prayer
many of you are praying for that cash or
praying for that relationship or praying
for that outcome to be exactly as you
want it to be in the time that you want
it to happen
but the secret to prayer
is to forget what you think you need
when we begin to stop praying for what
we think we need but instead begin to
pray for what is of the highest good for
all
that's when we get lit up
that's when invisible doors begin to
open for us that's when we align with
the truth and the magnitude of the
presence of our authentic power
so take that in doesn't that just feel
awesome just to say that i want to pray
for what is of the highest good for all
this doesn't that feel awesome
to even think about that thing that
you've been controlling and holding on
to and simply say to yourself right now
you know what i'm just going to pray for
what's of the highest good for all
takes the pressure off right
yeah
the second step is to start to focus on
what's thriving
we focus so much on what's not working
we so focus on the absence of something
why don't we focus on what's already
thriving in our lives when i started to
take the focus off of this baby that i
thought i needed to manifest in this
exact amount of time and started
focusing on the beauty in my marriage
focusing on my physical well-being
focusing on the spiritual journey that i
needed to go on i began to uncover
things about myself i didn't even know
and i started to let myself off the hook
and realign and get connected and i
started to feel that pressure of needing
that thing
just dissipate
so when you begin to take your focus off
of that thing you need and start to
focus on what is already thriving let me
just say something to you all you are
thriving because you are at super soul
sessions today okay
you are thriving right now you were
playing the drums this morning with
oprah okay you are good
let's focus on that
the third step
obstacles are detours in the right
direction
so what i realized was that this
obstacle of not getting pregnant right
away was actually a detour in the right
direction it was a detour towards my
spiritual connection it was a detour
towards hitting another bottom in my
life so that i could have another
awakening rumi says that the wound is
the place where the light enters you
in that wound i was awakened and i was
given these steps that i was blessed
with and this journey of developing my
spiritual condition in a way that i
needed to really badly
and that obstacle of not getting
pregnant was exactly as it needed to be
my baby was up there going not now
we had a plan
and i needed to go through this journey
so maybe you can begin to look at your
obstacles of maybe that divorce
is a opportunity a detour in the right
direction an opportunity to start to
love yourself some more
maybe that loss of that job is an
opportunity to begin to do that thing
you've been dreaming of
maybe that diagnosis is an opportunity
to get closer to god
take that in
let's reorganize your obstacles right
now what are the opportunities what is
the detour in the right direction in
what way can you begin to turn it upside
down and see it as an opportunity to
thrive and an opportunity to get more
connected to the truth
the fourth step
ask for a sign
we are always in communication with the
universe the universe is always giving
us messages it's just that we're not
listening
but when we ask we will always receive
it's the law we will receive
so asking for a sign that you're in the
right direction that you're on the right
path just last month i had to ask for a
sign
i took 2016 off from trying to make a
baby i i was just needing that break i
wanted to get back into my alignment
with my truth
and then
last month i decided
it's time let's make a baby
so i was getting into it i was getting
ready and i saw myself like clockwork go
right back to that old story right back
into my next book's coming out at this
time and what's going on with my
calendar and can my team handle this and
is everybody on board with my idea and
my vision but thankfully i'd been
spending the year in my five steps of
spiritual surrender so i had a little
bit more information and i was able to
stop myself in my tracks
so i stopped myself and i just i just
said
thank you universe
for showing me a sign
that i'm
in the right direction
later that day i'm looking out the
window of my office and i see these five
fat
wild turkeys just hanging out outside my
office they're just chilling outside my
office and i'm just in awe of these wild
turkeys they're so beautiful i sat there
for like a half an hour just staring at
them
two hours later i'm in my meditation and
i'm just doing my thing in my meditation
and i hear my intuition say google the
spiritual meaning of turkeys
okay
so i come out of my meditation i go to
my my computer and i type in what is the
spiritual meaning of turkeys
the spiritual meaning of turkeys
is fertility
that was the exact message that i needed
to hear
and when we allow ourselves to get into
the wonder
and the magnificence
of the guidance that is around us and
within us
that's when we truly start living
the universe once again was guiding me
so ask for a sign and you will receive
and it is your job to listen people
because you all may be asking for your
signs and you may be getting your
messages but you're not listening so ask
and listen
give yourself the chance to truly listen
and take that spiritually aligned action
from that place of that wisdom
and the final step the fifth step is
when you think you've surrendered
surrender more
my favorite line from a course in
miracles is those who are certain of the
outcome can afford to wait and wait
without anxiety
that presence of certainty is available
to all of us when we get aligned
when we truly surrender when we ask and
listen and let the universe show us
where to go and what to do rule number
seven practice true manifestation with
michael bernard beckwith first level is
the level of when people manifest
basically what they're seeking to
manifest is something that has been
given to them by society by their
parents something that's become popular
in the world and they use the sacred
laws of manifestation to get the things
that they want
and oftentimes later on discover
that
it wasn't really true manifestation
it wasn't really something born out of
the calling of their soul it was just
something that was popular in the moment
and they received it and they were
temporarily happy only to discover that
a few weeks later the the intrinsic joy
was not really activated many people
operate at that level
then there's what is called true
manifestation true manifestation is when
you're bringing something into
expression but along with it you're
cultivating your soul you're becoming
more yourself so at the end of the
manifestation if it's a true
manifestation not only have you brought
something into the visible world but
you've also changed you've also
transformed
true manifestation is akin to what i
call the law of radiance which is you're
not trying to attract something to
yourself
you're seeking to have the frequency and
the vibration that you already have it
and then you radiate to that frequency
and then that frequency that vibration
then condenses itself into your needs
met condenses itself into open
opportunities beautiful opportunities it
condenses itself into possibilities it
condenses itself into new things coming
into your life
but not without you becoming more you
and so over the number of years many
people have been operating under the old
law of manifesting which is to imagine
something and to let your mind embrace
it and this to get what you want
it's old it's outdated
it's entry level at its best
true manifestation says that what i want
i have it
and i do not want anything
that doesn't come with
the emergence of more me more of my
authentic self
do you realize that when a farmer plants
a seed
there's no cause and effect relationship
it's not making
that
thing happen
the seed is planted in fertile soil
and that which is already within the
seed emerges
it becomes visible
we live in a field of infinite potential
we are infinite beings so what's really
happening with true manifestation
something is emerging that's already
there
and then you'll understand something
else
you'll understand bliss many people
never get to bliss they hang out in
temporary happiness a temporary
counterfeit happiness based on a
temporary circumstance
bliss comes from the activation of your
potential
in true manifestation your potential is
activated and you find yourself in
greater states of bliss
and ecstasy
of which most people never have a chance
to even embody because they're caught up
in temporary counterfeit happiness based
on circumstance and rule number eight
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is create an image with
rhonda byrne what you want is you want
your manifestation to be as effortless
as possible
first reason is
if you are really efforting
it means you don't believe you have it
already
and you know with the creative process
it's ask believe receive and the biggest
step of all is to believe you already
have it then the second thing is
and this is really important because
this i learned from the secret to the
greatest secret and so when at the time
of the secret i would imagine that i had
to manifest something in the world right
something physical in the world that
just seems so big
oh my gosh i've got to manifest this
solid solid thing in the world when in
truth we already know that there's
nothing solid we put a microscope on our
body it's mostly space you know it's
just it's like a trick really that
everything looks solid but it it isn't
the case and so what i came to
understand is
you're not creating something solid all
you have to do is create an image that's
it
just an image it's not the really hard
thing of creating something solid like
i'm going to create a glass of water no
you are just going to have an image in
your mind
of you drinking a glass of water for
example and that is all you have to do
that's it that is so easy it's really
really easy and so you keep doing that
until you believe
and that's how effortless it is so if
you feel that you're trying to manifest
something and you're really kind of
efforting
you don't want that because it just
means you don't believe yet so that
means you've got more work to do
to really get yourself to believe more
imagining more visualizing more
affirmations because the our mind is
just a program that's all it is and so
if it's not believing that you have
something it's simply because of
thoughts you put into it before and so
all you need to do is put thoughts in
that you have something and keep
visualizing because visualizing is just
thoughts in pictures okay that's all it
is it's the same thing it's thought it's
just thought in pictures and so keep
visualizing keep thinking if you don't
like visualizing just just use thought
works just as well
and um and the moment you believe it
will it will manifest
you need to set a goal so big that
you'll never achieve it set a goal
that you will never accomplish
that's never going to happen
and you wake up every day trying to make
it happen that's called a mission
and it's way more important than setting
short-term goals for yourself
i got inspired by ted turner if you know
ted turner he's a billionaire
entrepreneur
worth over two billion dollars mega
philanthropist uh donated over a billion
dollars to the united nations and doing
lots of work in the community and
he got inspired when his father killed
himself so his father was an
entrepreneur he wanted to become a
millionaire build a million dollar
business and he did
he did it his father hit his goal he
became a millionaire
and then he killed himself
because he realized that life was
basically just still the same
he thought somehow life was going to be
different on the other side of hitting
the goal but he realized he woke up but
he's still the same person and so he
killed himself
and ted seeing that he was he was uh i
think in his late teens or early 20s at
the time just decided you know what i'm
going to set a goal for myself that's so
big that i'm never going to accomplish
it it's never going to happen and then
you wake up every day trying to make
that happen i think it's really
important uh i think especially for
achievers
you have set goals for yourself
and you've hit them
and then this is momentary little
celebration like i hit it hit my goal
and then what do you feel
a lot of people feel depressed
until you find out what's next
there's a great saying
of beyond the mountain there's more
mountains and i love it because the goal
isn't just to climb one mountain the
goal is to keep climbing you want to
climb forever
the the number one most common rule for
success that i see over and over and
over again is you have to love what
you're doing you have to like the
process of doing what you're doing the
process not just the result the the goal
is the results right hitting some goal
hitting hitting that financial goal
hitting a customer goal hitting a
subscriber goal it's just the results
you have to enjoy the actual work that
you're doing you have to enjoy the
process and the most successful people
actually enjoy the work that they're
doing
yes you have to make money in the
process yes you have to have an impact
in the process but you like the process
you like actually doing the work
when you want to grow
when you feel like you're on a mission
when you feel like the work you're going
to wake up every day and do is important
that's when you actually start getting
some crazy results at the same time
where if you set your goal only just to
hit some kind of results you end up
playing small for life
and end up not liking your life because
you felt it you know what it feels like
to hit a goal to feel the excitement and
then the next day you wake up and you're
still the same person
i think about when i hit my goals
when i hit my million subscriber goal i
got the gold plaque from youtube
i didn't need to celebrate i didn't want
to celebrate
because this is a celebration
making this video for you is the
celebration waking up and doing the work
every day is the celebration when i hit
2 million subscribers my audience was
asking hey
what are you going to do what are you
going to do for two and it's funny
because now we're coming up on three
million on the main channel and people
are starting asking what are you going
to do when you hit three
when i hit two
i actually did a live stream
as we crossed but i did it more for for
you guys it did more for the community
because
it's a journey together and and you guys
wanted to celebrate so i did we
celebrated together i did a live stream
q a as we crossed the subscriber goal
and then i actually felt
[Music]
guilty
afterwards i felt like should i
should i celebrate more is there
something wrong with me for not
celebrating
and so
i remember i said okay i'm going to do
this experiment we crossed 2 million
subscribers great benchmark uh i'm going
to go and take half the day off and we
went to
tim horton's a local coffee shop here
and i got a donut i got my favorite
donut and celebrated with the donut
and then came back
and i i just felt you know what nah this
is stupid let's go
work and i realized later like there's
nothing wrong with me because this is a
celebration
i get to i get to make videos for you
guys sitting here in the car
just talking to the camera as we drive
around doing errands
and knowing that people are watching
this and is having an impact and it's
making a difference at least that's the
intention
every time that is a celebration
and i think it's actually healthier i
think when you can switch
your celebration to the process of what
you're doing every day
your celebration is what's in your
calendar
instead of just
arbitrarily hitting some goal that how
often you actually get to celebrate like
you only get to celebrate your life once
a year when you've hit some goal how
about you celebrate your life every day
from the work that you're doing eighty
percent of you who use a vision book or
a vision board say
it changed me
i've told you about my vision board i
had it above my bed i wanted to get
married i wanted to go to africa and
here's a picture of my wedding was such
a here's a picture of me in africa
holding a lion that had been raised from
a cub with a family and it lived there
and it was amazing but i made these come
true i had that vision in my mind i held
that vision i'm
getting married i'm going on safari
and you're never given a vision without
an idea of making it real because what
you want wants you
what you are moving towards is moving
towards you have a vision or a dream or
a wish inside you
get it out of you
put it on paper look at it touch it
read it then you are making it real when
you can look at your vision write all
over your vision
write on it change it mix it up it's not
a dream
you're making
it real your potential expands as you
move towards it this will expand your
potential
when you move your mind to a new
dimension it never moves back
never right i wish i dream right i am i
do i can i will i always
i always exercise i can
fit exercise into my life i am
a fit person
i always pick healthy food i can find
healthy food wherever i go i'm the kind
of person that makes eating well a
master priority i can i do i am i always
inspire your mind turn it on with
exciting words turn it on with exciting
images so here's
a vision folder the other thing about
this vision book is it makes you
accountable as you look every day the
pictures of someone
doing yoga
or eating fruit you think well
i better stop looking at that and start
doing it every day as you look at
pictures somebody working from home
socializing looking after their body
horse riding
hiking
making salads as you look at it enough
you become inspired
to take action it motivates you it
inspires you it fills up your mind with
what you want
and it fills you up with a desire a
passion
it motivates you conditions you programs
you compels you to go after what you
want it holds you accountable
and it's so easy
so don't make it perfect it's science
that demystifies the mystical
and if you can combine a little quantum
physics with a little neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at possibility
and
if you talk about religion if you talk
about culture if you talk about
tradition even spirituality i noticed
that you divide an audience
but science in a sense creates community
so people come
for all kinds of reasons and what i've
learned in the last year or so is that
what people really want is wholeness
because when we want something or in
separation or in lack right
and so when we started
experimenting with doing different
scientific measurements one of the
things we started to notice is that when
a person
somehow connects
to something greater
and that has a influence on their
nervous system
the side effect is that they feel so
whole
so rejuvenated in that moment so blessed
by life
in that moment from an inner experience
that it's impossible for them to want i
mean
how can you want
when you feel whole right and so when we
started looking at heart coherence and
we saw this
tremendous
changes in
people's ability to be able to sustain
a state of mind a feeling in their heart
for an extended period of time
we have data to show you could be sick
and do that you could be a vegetarian
and do that you could be a carnivore and
do that you could be rich you could be
poor and it doesn't if you're skinny
overweight doesn't matter once you learn
that skill of self-regulation
and being able to experience a greater
level of wholeness
that if you can create from wholeness
instead of
separation or lack
you can produce greater effects
on the nature of reality so
we came from singularity and when you're
oneness or when your source
there's no separation between cause and
effect your thoughts create experiences
when you're in oneness we we journey
down the density and now we're really
separate from source
and so the
what what happens between cause and
effect is called time
so we're here now
to prove to ourselves that the divine
lives in us
so why not practice
shortening
time or the interval between cause the
thought and the effect the experience
and when you start seeing something
appear in your life as a result of you
at cause
you start getting more kind more caring
more loving more conscious more present
because you feel more whole so the basic
thing that neville taught me and a lot
of this is from the teachings of neville
uh neville goddard who died in the 1970s
he
he basically said that um all of us
have within us this
amazing capacity to manifest and attract
anything that we want into our life so
how we call it what what words that we
use we have to be able to say
um you know in the secret they say you
you get what you want you know and what
is missing and what neville said and
what has come to me and what i got from
the i am discourses and what i get from
the new testament which i read before i
did it is that you you say
i will attract into my life what i am
not what i want and i am capable of
attracting all things that
that the source is capable of attracting
so
that's the difference it's like you get
what you are rather than what you want
so you want to become you can't go
around and ask these divine beings you
know angels whatever you want to call
them who are right here all the time
you can't ask them to help me out you
have to
you have to become like they are that
when you're when you become angelic when
you become a divine being yourself when
you are giving when you are serving when
you are in that place they will come to
you that's what happened to you in india
you then begin to see yourself in
everything that's what the tao of ching
teaches as well they call it your
original nature your original nature is
reverence for all of life gentleness
kindness and service towards others
that's lao tzu 500 years before the
birth of christ saying that's our
original nature yes reverence for all of
life gentleness kindness service towards
other giving offering serving and when
you get to that place where you no
longer have any judgment within you
towards any of god's children that means
no condemnation no criticism no judgment
towards anyone even the osama bin laden
if enough of us get this message over if
enough of us get in that's just what my
mission is is just to teach people that
you are love you are divine put that
into your imagination i am i am well i
am happy i am content i am fulfilled
even if your senses tell you that you're
depressed one of your people that called
me when we did a pre-interview on here
said well if i if i'm feeling depressed
i'm supposed to fool myself and say i am
feeling well even you can't choose
another thought that's what i've had
absolutely and it's like you don't say i
am depressed because if you say i am
depressed
you connect with depression and the
universal source god whatever you want
to call it will align in such a way to
offer you whatever it is
yeah here's some more depression i am
unhappy i am depressed i am so by
placing into your imagination what you
want and assuming the feeling of that
wish is already fulfilled you go through
your life feeling that when enough of us
do that we will we will transform this
planet i'm telling you it can be done
well there's a primary law called the
law of vibration
the law of vibration decrees that
everything in this universe moves
nothing rests
the body in a coffin is moving
probably you're probably thinking this
guy's smoking something like if the body
in a coffin wasn't moving how would it
ever change to dust
it's always moving it's always vibrating
everything vibrates we live in a notion
of motion take a microscope and look at
a solid wall
it's not solid it only appears to be
solid or perception problem there you'll
see the wall moving right in front of
your eyes there's a particle of energy
and they're dancing right before your
eyes that's a lot of vibration the law
of vibration decrees everything moves
nothing rests we literally live in a
notion of motion now this physical
instrument we're living in we call our
body is a molecular structure and it's
in a very high speed of vibration
our brain is an electronic switching
station
when we activate brain cells we alter
the vibration in different parts of the
body i could not move my hand up and
down or my arm up and down without first
giving a message to my brain to do that
well the brain
activates cells in the body it sets up a
vibration in the body
the
vibration that the mind and body are in
is going to dictate what you attract
because when you put yourself in the
vibration what you're really doing is
put yourself on a specific frequency
that's what you do when you set a goal
most people set a goal and then wait for
it to happen and never going to happen
you've got to assume that it's already
happened you've got a picture of it in
your mind mentally it's already happened
it's happened because i've got the idea
in my conscious mind if i didn't have
the idea of my conscious mind i couldn't
talk to you about it the very fact i can
talk to you about it means that i've
already got it
then i've got to get emotionally
involved in it
i'm already emotionally involved in the
goal that i've got i've got it
intellectually i've got it emotionally
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form how does it move into form
well you attract whatever is required
for it to move into form you attract all
the energy that's necessary to produce
the physical result how do you do that
you do that by intellectually
emotionally staying in the vibration
of the good that you desire you see it
already in the present tense so that
keeps you on the frequency
and that frequency then dictates what
you're going to attract you can only
attract to you what's in harmonious
vibration with you
now if you're holding an image that you
can't get something you're on a
vibration
you're not going to get it but if you
can see yourself with it you know it's
coming to you you know it you know it's
only a period of time you're not quite
sure what the time is but you know it's
a period of time and bang that thing's
going to manifest in your life
you have controlled the vibration that
you're in the vibration then called the
frequency you put yourself in the
frequency that you good your desires on
let's suppose i want to have a lot of
money we're just talking about money now
this is a lot of money relative to
let's say
this there's one 100 here's 10 100 100.
so one's a lot relative to the other
neither one is a lot it just is
if i want to attract a lot of my i got
to see myself with a lot of money i got
to mentally accept i've already got it i
don't let my bank account dictate that i
choose that
so choosing myself to see myself with
the good i already desire i'm on that
frequency now the trick is to stay on
that frequency
most people look at the results and they
let the results dictate the frequency
they're on that's why they keep getting
the same results
they have the image in their mind
they're already reached the goal they
want they're already successful
and somebody else comes along and say
well you haven't got those results
in my mind i have but they're not
looking in my mind they're looking at my
present results and then pretty soon i
start listening to them i think god
they're right i look at my results i
haven't got it do you see why we keep
getting this poor results
you've got to see yourself with the good
you desire you've got to hold that image
in your mind you've got to know it's
going to come and that will attract
everything that's necessary see nothing
is created or destroyed
everything's already here if not in one
frequency certainly in another or not in
one state certainly in another we've got
to get on the frequency of the good that
we desire manifesting is acquiring the
experience of what it is that you want
to feel and being and living and
believing in that experience and then
allowing that experience to come into
form sometimes we manifest things far
beyond our wildest dreams so sometimes
if we have a vision of something it
happens in a far greater way so we want
to stay open yep so we can say i want
that macbook air but maybe we get that
macbook air that's a little bit bigger
than we thought yeah or maybe it comes
with an extra little gift yeah but
allowing ourselves to be open this or
something more manifesting is very
creative it is the process of using your
power energy and being in that presence
of your high-powered energy and allowing
that energy to co-create with the energy
that's around you so you're vibrating at
a high frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into this space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street if i
didn't believe in myself the way i do i
would never have manifested being on
marietv miracles occur naturally and
when they're not occurring something has
gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our
anxiety our our anger towards the past
that future tripping and projecting all
of that energy gets in the way of
allowing all of the miracles to occur
naturally the first type of
manifestation is to get very very clear
and you know if we're not clear about
what we desire then we can call in some
really funky stuff you must be clear
because if you are unclear you'll start
to call in some things that are not
really what you want you'll be confused
uh the other piece is that once you're
clear you can also then get clear about
all the ways that you don't believe all
of the limiting beliefs all the
negativity that might be blocking it i
once heard a definition of health that
made a lot of sense to me
good health it said
is having no fatigue
having a good appetite
going to sleep and awakening easily
having a good memory
having good humor
and having precision in thought and
action
not being klutzy
being honest
humble grateful and loving
how healthy are you
i do not heal anyone
the work i do is to help people
understand how their own mental patterns
are constantly creating their own life
experiences
all of them
the good experiences
and the so-called bad experiences
and also how these same mental patterns
are contributing to the ease
and dis-ease
in their bodies
we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every disease we have
it is the body's way of telling us that
we have a false idea in consciousness
our body is telling us
we are on the wrong track
and need to change the way we think
every illness
is a lesson
for us to learn
please do not just complain i want to
get rid of this condition it will not
create the healing you want
nor will you learn the lesson you need
to learn
this is not a time for condemnation or
for creating more guilt
we are just looking at what needs to be
released
this is a time for healing
for making our lives and our bodies
whole
i know you have within you all that you
need to accomplish this
once we begin to understand this process
we are able to take conscious control
of the changes we wish to make in our
lives
this is a very exciting process
and becomes one of the most important
adventures in our lives
i believe there is a center of wisdom
within each one of us
and when we are ready to make positive
changes in our lives
we attract whatever we need to help us
something inside of you has shifted
and the healing process has already
begun
you might even say that to yourself now
i have already begun the healing process
the body like everything else in life
is a mirror of our inner thoughts and
beliefs
the body is always talking to us if we
will only take the time to listen
every cell
responds to every single thought you
think
and every word you speak
continuous modes of thinking and
speaking produce body behaviors and
postures and eases or diseases
the person who has a permanently
scowling face
did not produce that by having joyous
loving thoughts
older people's faces and bodies
show so clearly a lifetime of inner
dialogue
how will you look when you are elderly
you see it is my belief that it is our
birthright to be totally healthy and
totally fulfilled
in every area of our lives take a nice
deep breath
and if possible
allow yourself to be in a comfortable
position
just let these ideas wash over you
only those ideas that are right for you
will be accepted by you
it doesn't matter whether you understand
them all or not
or if they make sense to you right now
your subconscious mind will hear and
record whatever you need
i believe that all illness is
self-created
not that we say i want to have this
illness
but we create a mental atmosphere where
this dis-ease can grow and flourish
our internal mental dialogue
reacts in every cell
in the body
i heard a physician say recently
if the surgeon operates on a patient
without doing something to help them
change the cause of the disease
then all the doctor is doing is
prolonging the life of the patient
until the patient can create another
dis-ease
you see we need to do more than just
treat the symptom
we need to eliminate the cause of the
dis-ease
and for that we need to go within
ourselves where the process of illness
began
it is my belief that we are each
responsible for every experience in our
lives the best and the worst
we all create our experiences by the
thoughts we think and the words we speak
the universe totally supports our
internal dialogue
our subconscious mind accepts as truth
whatever we choose to believe
you can say it either way
they both mean that what i believe about
myself and about life becomes true for
me
what you choose to think about yourself
and about life becomes true for you
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn to attract things when you
wake up with dr joe dispenza check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting